on va parler des Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 un événement attendu dans les
Yvelines et sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ou plusieurs
épreuves se disputeront VTT cyclisme
surprise BMX ou encore du golf en tant
que collectivité haute l'agglomération
et l'autorisation de sélectionner 1000
bénévoles pour en parler avec nous
Maxime Lucas chargé de promotion de la
vie sportive à Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
alors combien de candidatures de
bénévoles vous avez reçu pour
l'agglomération alors vous avez raison
grâce aux cinq épreuves accueillies sur
le territoire et au cas de sites
olympiques l'agglomération à le statut
de collectivité haute et ce statut nous
a permis de présélectionner 800
personnes
400 hommes et 400 femmes donc on avait
une base de données qui respectait la
mixité et donc pour recruter ses 800
personnes on a 1300 personnes qui se
sont inscrites sur notre plateforme
c'est pour sélectionner ces 800 du coup
on est passé par une phase de test où on
contacter le plus de d'associations du
territoire à inscrire leurs événements
récurrents sur l'année et à nous
demander s'ils avaient besoin de
bénévoles donc nous après on contactait
ces 1500 personnes on leur demandait
d'aller tester sur des postes de
bénévoles sur ces événements tests
alors c'était sur l'année 2022 ça donc
ils allaient sur des il y avait des
courses de vélo où ils ont été signal à
l'heure ils ont il y a eu des événements
culturels où ils étaient au niveau sur
des postes d'accueil ou d'orientation
des participants suite à ces événements
les organisateurs nous renvoyaient un
questionnaire l'idée c'était pas de
faire une évaluation très précise des
bénévoles mais de s'assurer finalement
de leur fiabilité s'ils étaient arrivés
à l'heure s'ils avaient respecté les
consignes qu'on leur avait donné et
s'ils étaient pas s'ils étaient pas
partis avant la fin de l'événement
et donc suite à cela nous on contactait
les bénévoles qui avaient respecté
leurs engagements ont récupéré des
informations supplémentaires qu'on a pu
après envoyer à Paris 2024 en fin
septembre donc 400 femmes et 400 hommes
quels sont les profils est-ce que ce
sont plutôt des jeunes plutôt des
personnes
âgées alors on a été relativement
agréablement surpris puisqu'on a eu
vraiment de tout type de profil des
étudiants alors il fallait il faut
savoir que Paris 2024 avait mis en place
des critères de sélection à des critères
relativement simples il fallait avoir 18
ans au premier janvier 2024
par les français ou anglais et être
disponible sur la période des Jeux
olympiques ou paralympiques et pas
forcément de manière consécutive et donc
les gens qui répondaient à ces critères
étaient vraiment des étudiants des
personnes actives ou des retraités qui
sont venus des 12 communes de
l'agglomération mais aussi en dehors de
l'agglomération avec un rattachement à
la gloss soit par
par une activité associative ou ils
étaient salariés d'une entreprise du
territoire et donc on a été vraiment
très agréablement surpris de voir une
multitude de profils s'inscrire à ce
programme elles seront quand si elles
sont vraiment sélectionnées pour devenir
bénévoles alors là
clôturé les inscriptions sur sa
plateforme nos 800 bénévoles comme tous
ceux qui avaient été présélectionnés par
les différentes collectivités hautes
avaient une quinze jours d'avance pour
s'inscrire et avait un filtre de
première sélection
et ils seront informés comme tous les
autres candidats à partir de fin
septembre s'ils sont retenus ou pas par
parler 2024 mais par contre si on
souhaite toujours devenir bénévole pour
ces Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 il y a
encore une porte ouverte puisqu'en juin
vous lancez un nouveau programme pour
devenir bénévole à 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est tout à fait ça il est encore
possible d'être acteur de ces jeux on a
tous vu que sur la billetterie il serait
compliqué d'avoir des places pour pour
assister aux épreuves il reste encore
des possibilités pour pour vivre
l'événement nous l'agglomération on met
en place c'est ça à partir du 24 juin un
programme destiné à recruter des
bénévoles pour les missions qui seront
de la responsabilité de lagglomération
l'accueil et l'orientation en gare
jusqu'au site de compétition il faut
savoir que les bénévoles qui seront
présents sur ces sites seront les
premières les premiers visages que
verront les spectateurs du monde entier
qui vont se rendre à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc 360 000
personnes qui vont venir sur le
territoire et donc les nos bénévoles
seront les premiers visages les premiers
sourires que c'est spectateurs vont
découvrir en arrivant ils ont un rôle
important c'est ça très important et et
vraiment ils vont être à la rencontre de
spectateurs qui vont venir du monde
entier donc vraiment quelque chose
d'enrichissant donc nous sur ce
programme de recrutement on a une
première phase qui va être de recenser
les les candidatures jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 20 3 et en candidature un peu
alors on ouvre le plus largement
possible et on tape sur quelques
centaines de postes pour voir avec une
priorité donnée aux habitants et aux
acteurs de 50 ans en Yvelines et suite à
cette première phase de recrutement on
va être sur une phase de formation de
ces bénévoles pour qu'il y ait une vraie
plus-value pour les personnes qui seront
à l'intérieur de ce programme et qu'elle
puisse avoir un enrichissement grâce à
cette pratique bénévole donc on a vu
avec Paris 2024 pour avoir tous leurs
contenus de formation à disposition pour
nos bénévoles on s'appuiera aussi sur
des associations du territoire sur de
secourisme sur des petites formations
aux langues étrangères pour accueillir
dans différentes langues les spectateurs
du monde entier voilà l'idée c'est que
les les bénévoles qui seront présents
sur les jeux pour 50 ans en Yvelines
puissent avoir toutes les cartes en main
pour pour assurer au mieux leurs
missions et avoir la meilleure
expérience possible
ça vous tente ou autour du plateau de
Noël pour les Olympiques à 50 ans en
Yvelines oui toute seule
[Rires]
traiter l'information et peut-être
interviewer les bénévoles qui assurent
ces missions autour ou à l'intérieur des
sites olympiques à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et justement
est-ce que est-ce que ces personnes là
qui vont qui vont candidater en juin
sauront sur quel lieu elles vont pouvoir
être bénévoles ou ce sera un peu du
hasard
alors l'idée c'est de voir avec les
personnes qui s'inscrivent là où elles
souhaitent être bénévole
ça sera forcément sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et sur deux
missions bien distinctes la première on
l'a vu c'est laquelle rotation entre les
gars et les sites de compétition puisque
les sites de compétition après relève de
la responsabilité de parler 2024 et le
deuxième
site sur laquelle les bénévoles pourront
interagir c'est sur la ce grand espace
de célébration qui qui va prendre place
au coeur du territoire et donc là on
sera sur un village olympique une fan
zone on sait pas encore quel
dénomination favora mais là il y aura
besoin de bénévoles pour animer cet
espace et faire que tout se déroule pour
le mieux et que ça soit un super site on
puisse vivre les jeux pendant la
quinzaine olympique quelles sont les
pistes des lieux évoqués si vous pouvez
le dire je sais pas mais c'est les
pistes des lieux évoqués pour accueillir
ce village olympique sera ouvert
finalement à l'ensemble du public alors
on peut le dire ce site il
vivra au milieu des sites olympiques il
sera sur l'île de loisirs à proximité
immédiate du vélo Drôme et du stade de
BMX et à proximité aussi immédiate de la
colline d'Élancourt au 01 les épreuves
de VTT
l'idée c'est d'avoir un grand site où on
ne fait pas que regarder les jeux mais
on pourra aussi s'initier à plein de
pratiques sportives on veut que ça soit
un lieu culturel où il y ait des des
concerts on est vraiment dans la
création de cet espace mais on le veut
très ambitieux on veut que tous les cinq
continents puissent vivre les jeux et
puis cette présence sur cet espace on
veut que les spectateurs du monde entier
se disent ah ben 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est super je vais y rester un peu plus
longtemps que prévu je vais pas juste
aller au Vélodrome mais je vais rester
sur la Fan Zone et donc ça va être un
super équipement pour vivre l'Olympique
quoi
ces Jeux Olympiques à 50 ans en Yvelines
merci merci Lucas d'avoir répondu à
notre question je le rappelle vous êtes
chargés de promotion de la vie sportive
pour 50 ans en Yvelines